OK, so the next thing that we need
to look at within the context of lightmaps and lightmaps,
view modes and visualizers are going
to help us understand what's actually
going on under the hood when it comes to performance
optimization.
So the categories that we're going
to cover for the visualizers are
going to be light complexity and lightmap density.
Now, they're really easy to access.
All you have to do is go to the View Mode tab
and go to Optimization Modes and choose either of these.
In the case of lightmap complexity,
it's going to be View Mode, Optimization View
Modes, and Light Complexity.
It'll give you, essentially, a colored view,
as you can see here, of the scene that
explains how complex a particular lighting setup is
for a given pixel.
So you'll notice that overlapping movable lights
will be very expensive.
They'll go closer to the pink-white range.
And you'll see the static lights are basically free.
So bake your light wherever possible
if you're using the lightmap solution,
because it will be the cheapest way of rendering your scene.
The next one is going to be lightmap density, which
is going to be in the same spot just right below it.
And it displays the density based on the tessellation
display.
Try and keep your lightmaps as low as possible.
And essentially, this will help in general
with baking and optimization, baking times specifically.
So let's go ahead and take a look at how this actually
works.
So if I go into the editor with the project
that you've been supplied for this,
I've gone to my interior scene.
So we're going to Light in 103.1, Interior,
and I've just opened the level.
Let's take a look at how we can see those optimization
view modes.
So I'm going to go to my View Mode tab,
go to Optimization View Modes, and look at Light Complexity.
So here, you can see the areas
where light is basically fully baked, very, very little
performance impact.
But the more dynamic in certain areas the lights become
and the more overlapping we have,
the more expensive it becomes.
Let's take a quick look at it.
If I just add a light now without building
and essentially calculate it as dynamic.
So I'll go to Lights, Point Light, and drag one in.
And I set it as Moveable.
So we're not technically needing to build this,
but this is being calculated at runtime, right?
So if I take a look at that lighting complexity again,
you'll notice it starts to get really expensive.
As I duplicate lights and have overlaps of those light
radiuses, you'll see it grows exponentially almost.
So something to keep in mind, again, bake whatever you can.
But as I say, this View Mode here
is going to help you a lot to understand
why your frame rate might be dropping in certain areas
due to lighting.
So the next thing is going to be Optimization View Modes,
Lightmap Density.
And you can see here, it allows
you to see the density of a particular mesh.
Now, if a mesh, for example, was a little too high,
for example, these small ones, it'll appear as red.
And that's just down to the resolution
that it has per size on the screen or density.
So one thing you can do is you can overwrite
the lightmap resolution.
And let's say, for example, I set this to 1024.
You can see it shows us much smaller little squares,
and it starts to give us the information
on the visualization mode here that it's
a little higher than the rest of the scene around it.
So that's something to keep in mind.
One other thing to keep in mind with this
is that it's better to have the general scene kind of have
an overall similar tone.
And the reason for this is if you have a very high resolution
mesh here or lightmap resolution here compared
to this one, you'll probably start
to notice differences in the resolution of the shadows.
And that's something to keep in mind
because it can make things a little bit more noticeable
in that sense.
So try and keep things nice and consistent.
And that's really it for visualization view modes
in terms of lighting.
Next, we'll take a look at IES profiles.